foreign
these machines haven't stopped since two
earthquakes struck to kill Southern
cities
neither have these employees at this
Turkish red crescent Factory
every day 500 tents are sawn here and
delivered to survivors in the region
millions of them urgently need shelter
this earthquake affected 10 cities
that's why our capacity functions are
different this time we always had long
shifts while producing for previous
earthquake regions we are overwhelmed
working selflessly
it's winter and it's cold and these
devastated cities people's needs are
acute
to meet the demand all tent
manufacturers in the country have been
mobilized the Turkish red crescent is a
major contributor
our tents were created specifically for
earthquake and winter conditions family
tents are 16 and a half square meters in
size they are resistant to water fire
and mildew
blankets food medical supplies
containers and mobile toilets are also
urgently needed
the Turkish president has asked
people to the areas to bear with them
for a year so he can build them new
homes that's as recovery efforts turn
into accommodating survivors who don't
even have temporary shelters
the two earthquakes impacted the lives
of more than 13 million people
displacing at least half of them
president reject a ipardon is promising
new homes within a year
but with turkey facing one of its worst
earthquake disasters eight organizations
are likely to face a longer mission
solo Al Jazeera Ankara